quickly want to just recap this week um
the
governor gave his state of the state
address he released his budget for the
upcoming session everyone
i think seems to agree it's going to be
difficult uh what was your takeaway from
the governor's proposed budget
and how things are going to play out up
in carson city
well i think he was able to you know put
together
you know a lot i think a better budget
than we anticipated
based on the circumstances that we're in
you know we were expecting
you know the the the uh revenues
to be really bad and they're not good
but they're better than what we
originally thought so that's good
um and he looked at you know a lot of
things that we really need to prioritize
so
you know i think when it comes to you
know economic development those kind of
things i think
he did a really good job with what he
was given
considering where things were after the
special session over the summer and the
cuts back then obviously
the governor wants to reinstitute a good
chunk of that
are you concerned that his the basis of
some of the funding is
too optimistic there's a lot of leaning
on federal assistance
is there too much optimism come from the
governor's office
i don't think so i i think that uh there
is some optimism right now you know
there's a change in
the administration and there's a desire
to help
um you know even before they with the
with the previous administration they
they they helped
um so this is even more help that that
they're offering so
i think you know for us to really get
through this we're really going to need
some help
and i think that's where that optimism
is coming from
without that i mean there would be have
to be some other massive
cuts um let's talk education
um the the funding formula
obviously was a it has been a major
issue that you have been touting for
for a long time what are the chances
that
that
gets fully implemented during this
session
so i mean we're going to look at that um
we're trying i'm trying to
to understand uh what the governor's
proposing in in his
proposal it's it's very important
for us to implement this new funding
formula it's transparent
makes it easy for everybody to
understand where the money's going
and it focuses education funding on
education
so i think we all have that goal to make
sure that that happens and that's what
we're working towards
but in in i guess in the hierarchy of
priorities specific to
education given the circumstances with
the pandemic just getting kids back in
class where does uh
finishing the funding formula
adjustments where does that fit on your
priority scale
well i think that's the number one thing
we need to do keep in mind the funding
formula is not
about how much money we're putting into
education it's how we allocate it
and having a transparent um funding
formula
that allows us to i mean even if we're
just looking at it we want to make
adjustments
it's very easy under the new formula to
make those adjustments
so for me it's very important that that
gets implemented because over
over 10 years just with doing nothing
else over 10 years it's going to add
over a billion dollars to our education
funding
because of the focus on education and
having its own
education uh rainy day fund
and just you know just keeping the money
with education
so for me that's that's that's uh that's
my
number one priorities to make sure that
we get that implemented
um what kind of
acknowledging that the democrats you
know control things just some
the houses up in in carson city but how
much of a
fight over money is there going to be
this legislative session compared with
the other ones it's always
a bit of a dog fight up there there's
not
no endless supplies of funding to go
around but when you
when everyone gets together and you
start to talk
how much of a scramble is it going to be
well i think everybody
is anticipating that you know we're not
going to have
any extra money we've got what we have
and i think people are more
understanding as we get up there
i don't think there's a lot of proposals
i don't think people have a lot of
proposals that
that are going to require a lot of extra
money
and so i i think people are going to be
willing to to sit down and work together
you know to make sure that uh whatever
proposals come forth that we can work
together on that and i think that's true
um in both houses i think it's true um
across the aisle um i think we all want
to work together and know that there's a
limitation on what we can do
education aside what are some other
measures some other issues that you hope
to tackle or
uh put your support behind uh
when the session starts well definitely
one of the things that
you know in addition to all the issues
that you know education
and the pandemic has pointed out in
education and inequities
i think economic development needs to be
another huge
issue that we that we need to tackle we
need to find ways to
expand you know the way that we
currently
bring in revenues for the state is very
limited
there's only certain ways you can do
that so the only way you're really going
to increase
revenues is to change our economy
in a way that we're bringing in
additional revenues from
you know we're so dependent on on
tourism
gaming and we've got to find other ways
to bring other
industries so that you know when we have
a pandemic like we do
right now tourism is the first thing to
go and it's usually the last thing to
come back
and so we want to make sure that we have
other industries here to help us be able
to
to get through these tough times but you
know the governor talked a lot about
that trying to
you know increase the innovation in the
economy but that's a long-term
project that's not you know all of a
sudden tomorrow switch is joined by a
million other
similar tech companies here it seems
though that nevada needs some short-term
fixes is there anything short-term that
the legislature can do
besides wait for federal funding
as far as increasing right now any
short-term things would have to be
things like
making sure that we're um that the
internet
um for example things that are purchased
on the internet that we're getting
those sales tax revenues that's
something that could be
more immediate you know any adjustments
that we would want to make
to any of the existing taxes could bring
more that way
but you know this is a tough time to to
look at those issues and see what we can
do more
in the immediate so things like you know
trying to figure out ways that we can
save and maybe do things more
efficiently
and we've been doing that for years and
so we're pretty slim when it comes to
all of that
there's at the end of the day we've got
to make sure that
that we're working on the long-term
things because um
it's never going to come to pass if we
don't start that process
now and at the same time we're going to
be looking through the budget
seeing everything that we can do on both
the expenses and the revenue side
let's see what can happen um as far as
bringing any additional revenues
you were kind of hinting at uh with
regards to bringing in revenue
uh increasing taxes um
you know as we're talking about for
example resorts gaming et cetera
if there are fewer people visiting and
you're trying to encourage people to
visit
but then you're also on the back end
raising the taxes on those visitors
those seem to be those kind of seem to
they'd be in opposition though
right yeah i mean it's not a great time
to be
raising revenue um because like like i
said we're so dependent on the
tourism you know and uh so i don't i
don't know where we go
in that respect as far as um you know
is there places that we can look
sometimes though there are you know as
you look at the legislation and you look
at
you know there might be places where
we're currently not receiving
uh taxes that we requested um
i'm not sure i think i i i
that's something that uh we're looking
at
um but i don't i don't have any real
specifics
i mean i know i've heard of some um some
things that are going on
but i haven't i don't have any
information on it at this point
um to know if that's something but you
know i think that the internet
looking at the internet tax thing is is
an important um
uh issue that we've been doing and some
of the big companies have already been
paying those taxes
so i i don't know that we're gonna find
you know there's no magic bullet
you're not gonna find some brand new tax
that
that nobody um has ever heard of um
and and implement something like that i
just don't see us
implementing any new and and the other
thing there really is
no way to do anything short term um
as far as increases in revenues that
that would be brand new because anything
brand new that you implement
um you wouldn't actually by the time you
set it up and get going you're already
mostly done with the next two years so
it really doesn't help with this budget
so it all comes down to the the federal
assistance
right right the only thing immediate
could be any
federal assistance that we can get and
and i think the other thing
um that that is real would be really
helpful uh both in education and in in
all aspects because the health
healthcare and all of that is having
flexibility
if we're allowed to have flexibility
where our hands aren't tied
that money has to be spent a specific
way
and if we don't spend it then we can't
use it
so if we can if we could be flexible and
be able to spend it in the areas that we
need to know that that's
that's another way to actually get more
with actually
not really getting more revenue but
giving giving us the ability to actually
spend it in the areas that we need to
and be more efficient in that respect
i'm out of questions uh anything else
um i you know i think that on on the
education front i think the other issues
that we're really gonna
look at and tackle is how do we move
forward into the future
with the things that we've learned you
know one of my big things that i'm
working on
with the department of ed is
competency-based education
where you know we have the ability for
for kids to actually move it
at their their own pace um which could
be helpful
that's one tool that we implemented as a
as a
trial over the last few years but now we
want to look to see if there's a way to
implement in a larger scale
um so that you know in some aspects
we could educate kids better uh
some in some cases faster some might
need more time but
you know those kinds of things and any
other things that have come up during
the pandemic
that allow us to look at where the
inequities are and be able to
um put some things in place that will
help us fix those inequities
and educate all of our kids to the best
that we can and
i think that's important that we work on
this session
all right thanks for the time appreciate
it alrighty good luck and
thanks again for taking the time this
morning appreciate a lot